le mode opératoire les mots qu'il a
prononcés lorsqu'il est passé à l'acte
allah ouakbar confirme la piste
terroriste le procureur de la république
s'est exprimé juste après le premier
ministre pour donner l les premiers
éléments de l'enquète est justement
expliqué la saisie du parquet national
anti terroriste écouter le parquet
national anti terroriste s'est saisi du
crime qui a été commis en début d'après
midi ici à rambouillet les raisons de
cette saisine sont les suivantes en
preniez le déroulement même des faits
qui comprend des éléments de repérage
également la réalisation d'effets
modalités mêmes du crime la personne de
la victime mais aussi les propos tenus
par l'auteur au moment de la réalisation
des faits ce sont l'ensemble de ces
éléments qui nous ont décidé à accepter
notre saisine ce que nous avons donc
décidé ce que l'on sait pour maman de
l'assaillant un tunisien de 36 ans
arrivé en france en 2009 en situation
irrégulière il en obtenir un titre de
séjour grâce à un emploi à deux
chauffeurs livreurs qui expirera fin à
il habitait depuis peu à rambouillet son
domicile a été perquisitionné se trouve
à une dizaine de minutes du commissariat
ils auraient repéré les lieux en amont
de son acte barbare en tout cas l
émotion est palpable ici importe où les
rivera qu'on a pu interroger rambouillet
une commune sans problème une commune
plutôt tranquille est la police
nationale a rendu un vibrant hommage à
stéphanie cette fonctionnaire de police
morte à l'âge de 49 ans et mère de deux
enfants du côté des syndicats la colère
vient elle remplacer la tristesse c'est
le cas de françois bersani secrétaire
général gp de la police ait des yvelines
qui appelle le gouvernement à prendre
ses responsabilités
le premier sentiment là que qui va
habiter tous les policiers de ce
département les policiers de ce
commissariat de rambouillet les
policiers français dans leur ensemble et
bien oui c'est le chagrin c'est la peine
perdre une femme de 45 ans deux enfants
une mère de famille administrative qui
travaillent dans ce commissariat comme
agent d'accueil c'est terrible c'est
terrible c'est n'est pas en plus la
première fois que notre commissariat
afin que le nôtre département plutôt est
en deuil et nous avons perdu un couple
de collègues en 2016 à magnanville
jessica et jean baptiste
nous avons un professeur d'histoire
assassiné l'an dernier aujourd'hui 1
pauline policière dans ce commissariat
de rambouillet aujourd'hui c'est vrai
que après le chagrin après l'émoi ici là
la colère je pense qu'il va prendre
place à savoir que la sécurité a été
renforcée devant tous les commissariats
et toutes les gendarmeries à de france l
enquête de son côté suit son cours pour
rappel elle a été confiée conjointement
à la direction centrale de la police
judiciaire et à la dg et si un nouveau
drame